hi i had an idea
and like most of my ideas it was
probably pretty stupid i am going to be
watching the same video 100 times in a
row
because i feel like it and because i
have been away for a little bit and uh
finally got back into town
and what better way to
use my time
than to watch video
a hundred times
in a row
so hello hi
yes i'll get started in a little bit you
might notice a little counter right here
or a number right now but that number
will go up every time i hit this button
which will hopefully
play the video in question hello hi
welcome i'm just going to wait a little
bit before we get started because once
we get going there's going to be very
little time to actually stop
because
because once we get going
there's just going to be you know a lot
of watching so
glad you all are here for the journey uh
if you're watching this in the future
after this has been done
uh you will know if i've succeeded or
not
which i'm sure i will i don't see why
not all i got to do is sit here and
watch a video
which isn't so bad
um
but
also i'm quite tired
because like i said i just got back in
town i was out for uh the in space with
markiplier sound mixing to finalize
the show
and
to make the trailer for it which i hope
you saw
um hello hi hello you'll know the video
in just a moment you guys will figure
out the video in just a moment um this
is also a good moment for me to catch up
so a lot of people were like oh where is
he i haven't seen a video in a little
bit i've been traveling um and i just
got back last night
as i think i've said before like i said
a little tired
yeah
hello hello okay this is enough people
i'm gonna get going and once we get
going there's going to be very little
stopping
and the video is very special to me it's
something
near and dear to my heart
um but i've done the math this is
probably going to take about
like four hours
to watch this 100 times
so a hundred times coward do two hundred
i might we'll see how i feel we'll see
if we blast through this first hundred
maybe i'll go to two hundred maybe i'll
go to three hundred i'm probably not
going to go to three hundred let's just
see
how we get
and then i'll update the title of the
video
after we're done
okay cool all right here we go
got him
got you [ __ ] this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
oh wow
large object on collision course with
ship
impact
it's up to the captain
bad leadership
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who have trusted you which
means that if i'm seeing it i must be
crazy but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back
and i come back and i always come back
and everything
has to be
oh
okay
so that's one sorry it's still loud for
a bit there
hold on
hold on
all right so uh yeah it worked god i
took forever to set up this automatic
thing where it would play it at a number
and then go back to the main screen here
so
the main reason for this live stream and
i'm going to pause it one for now and
then i'll i am going to watch this 99
more times and the reason is because i
cut this trailer myself um and when i
made it like i was exceptionally proud
of it um but the sound mixing was
actually done by the same people or same
person who
did the sound mix for the show
in space with markiplier which if you
didn't know and you haven't seen that
trailer already go watch it on my
channel uh the homework is a hundred
times in a row if you can't do that what
are you weak
what are you pitiful
anyway
i'm really proud of it i'm really proud
of the show and uh now that it's finally
out the trailer anyway is out the show
is not out that comes out april 4th
april 4th
in space with markiplier comes out april
4th
april
4th
which is in less than a month but now
that this trailer is finally out i can
finally start talking about it um
because i've been obviously very cryptic
and you know there's been a few trailers
here and there little teaser trailers uh
but for the most part it has literally
been just
silence and that's you know i i like to
keep things
close to the chest when it comes to
projects for spoiler reasons but also
just because you know it's not ready i
don't want you to see it just yet april
4th and it's free
for those of you don't know it's free
it's free
it's free
so
when april 4th comes around you all know
what to do am i right i am right
i am absolutely right
now
uh what i want to say also is the reason
april 4th is an important date and why
that date was picked i did see a lot of
people uh congratulating me for 10 years
on youtube and that's going by the date
that i created
my previous youtube channel for those of
you who don't know this is kind of lore
into the backstory of uh
the markiplier channel history i had a
channel that i made on march 6
uh
2012
and
that is actually not my 10 year
anniversary
because what i consider
to be my 10 year anniversary on youtube
is the day that i first uploaded a video
to youtube which if you you might have
guessed it already
is april 4th
2012.
on that day i will have been doing
youtube and uploading fairly
consistently
for
10 years
which is kind of a big milestone i don't
get another one of these and uh
this is kind of all
i don't know it's just really special
that
i was able to get this project to come
out on that day
because it it really kind of tells tale
of like where i've come from in the past
10 years and not that i don't appreciate
everybody making the 10-year celebration
stuff for march 6. i do appreciate it i
haven't looked at any of it yet maybe if
i get through this hundred i will watch
and look at some of the stuff that you
guys have made for that because i do
appreciate that um but i love
that i'm able to release this on my
10-year anniversary because
it's the culmination of everything that
i've wanted to do right
so when i started youtube and this is
more like super backstory in terms of my
time
on youtube
um
i actually
it's funny markiplier was my throwaway
channel i didn't think i wanted that to
be like my name on youtube so i just
made that
with a couple other ideas i had for
usernames
and my original idea was to make videos
where i star in every role that was my
original intention to making youtube
videos or making content on youtube
and
i didn't know how to do that 10 years
ago i didn't know how to hold a camera
10 years ago i didn't know the first
thing about editing a video 10 years ago
i didn't even know how to cut a video 10
years ago
so when it comes down to
then having this like goal of doing
videos where i kind of like duplicate
myself in all the videos um
you know that's that's kind of where the
concept of like markiplier came in
because i was going to multiply
myself but markiplier was going to be
the
like backup
[ __ ] content dump channel
um and so when i didn't figure out how
to do that
i turned around i was like okay what can
i do and my brother i think i've
mentioned this before but my brother
watched let's plays and it was people
playing video games and posting videos
of it i was like okay
i can do that i can do that until i
learn enough to be able to do the things
that i want to do
and now 10 years later after
10 years of making videos making
sketches making uh shows actually
uh to culminate to this one
like that's really special for me
that's that's really something and it's
kind of crazy to see how far i've come
and
like i i think i can honestly say that i
have accomplished my goal
or what i wanted to do when i first
started to do youtube you know
and uh it's it's just
oh man it's just really fun and this
show is so fun
i i think you're gonna love it i really
do if you liked heist if you like date
if you like my videos in general or
anything that i've done
you're gonna love this one
and just uh
yeah i'm really proud of how far i've
come
and anyway
that's all i gotta say about that
quiz time when is the show coming out
hmm you should know that
i'm waiting there's a slight delay but
i'm waiting to see if you guys know when
it comes out
it comes out on my hint here's a hint
i'm on my 10 year anniversary of the
first yes very good very good give
yourself a round of applause you did
very good so
in honor of
that
i thought i could watch it 10 times
i'll watch it 100 times
the original idea was to watch it a
thousand times but then i did the math
of how long it would take me to watch it
a thousand times and i think um
it was like a week it would have taken
me like a week straight i didn't no no
not a week no
that's not that's not it it would have
taken me
oh no it would have taken me two days
two days straight to watch this trailer
a thousand times
and so
i'm not gonna do that so i'll go to a
hundred and i will
see how it goes from there all right
now buckle up because we're
we're in this i want to know i really
want to know take a screenshot of you
or no that won't prove anything you'll
just come back later
for those of you who are willing to
stick this out with me and watch this a
hundred times because in all honesty i
have watched this trailer already from
making it to
uh editing it to like doing the sound
mixing i've watched it well over a
hundred times and i'm still not bored of
it like even that time when the number
went up to one
i still love watching it i think it's
just super cool so anyway
buckle up
we're going for it
yeah
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well seen at
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and they come back
and i always come back and everything
has to be
oh
yeah it's a good one i still love it
like i i unironically still love it it
is fantastic um a quick thing before uh
before we move on to the next watch
um
if you guys have any questions
for
uh me
about the show things that aren't
related to spoilers about making the
show or things that you want to know
about what's going on right now that i'm
doing what i'm working on uh write them
in the comments um
moderators if you can assist me if you
see any good ones that aren't like
pertaining to spoilers or things that i
could ask
or i could answer
let me know like just a few you don't
need to get all of them just if you see
a good question bringing to my attention
in the discord i have it i'm looking in
there i have a window open anyway i'm
not looking in there um also
oh there was something i was going to
mention about that and i completely
forgot
it's gone it's gone
it's gone
i'll i'll find out what it is when i
watch it again here we go
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well we seem
to have this situation all under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come
back and everything
has to be
wow
still
i remember what it was i remember what
it was um
i
i remember
because when we were mixing it
uh
if you don't know if you're one of the
few people that have a good home theater
audio system
on youtube this is mixed in 5.1 surround
sound just like the show is the show is
actually mixed in 5.1 so if you watch
this on your home theater uh you can get
the full
sound experience um however i remember
talking to uh brad is the guy is the
name of the guy who mixed it uh i was
talking to brad about this um because
you know he usually works on movies and
tv shows right and and it's like things
that are going to be played in a theater
right uh because he's he's he's very
good about audio and like doing all of
that stuff and i like audio uh mixing
editing whatever you would call it uh
but he's like a wizard at it he's
incredible
but i broke his
heart
i shattered his soul i destroyed him you
know because he mixed this trailer in
5.1 surrounding like it's beautiful and
the audio is great
but i told him because he asked me like
he knew that like a lot of people
watched us on a phone but he was hoping
that i could tell you guys to watch it
like on a good
big screen with like good sound and i i
shattered him to bits when i told him
the statistics of
of where people watch these videos of
mine
when i told them that over 60 percent of
you guys watch this on a phone
and all of my videos on a phone this big
with phone speakers playing i don't know
if you have earbuds in or anything but
just like either phone speaker or just
like some cheap earbuds
the look on his face i'll try to
recreate it he was like
he was asking the question then just
and just i could see his heart just
shattered a bit
he was so
so
sad
and i was like yeah there's no way
around it so but this is my this is my
plea to you if you guys watch the
trailer on a good sound system you will
notice there's stuff going on all around
you i don't know if uh the
youtube app itself
will automatically figure out what you
have i have no idea i don't know if it's
like only certain apps i don't know if
you like
if you just airplay it or cast it or
something it'll do it but whatever
anyway
it's uh
it's good um i will get the questions on
the next one because i'm already taking
way too much time we're only at number
three give it up for number three give
it up for number four
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
brace for impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well worth
this situation all under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have
[Music]
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
oh it's good that's good i'm gonna do
one more
because i i don't i like we're way
behind my quota you know what i mean
we're way behind my quota okay
okay i see questions are popping up i've
got questions when i get to
when we get done with this one and i'm
watching it fully i have to watch it all
the way to the end
because
why wouldn't you do that why wouldn't
you do that
why wouldn't you do that
this is your ship correct oh yeah that's
my ship it's my pride and joy the
invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
braced impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very weird we don't
want to have this situation all under
control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad
leadership have you ever considered that
there is no right answer have we been
here
before
every mistake
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy everything has today
come back
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to be
oh man all right so like we'll pause and
i'll answer some questions and then
we'll do we'll like sprint through
another five and we'll see how we feel
and then we'll sprint through again and
we'll just keep cycling that over and
over again
forever until we get to
till we get to a hundred yeah
so uh there's something else i was gonna
say but i've completely forgotten what
it was oh yeah i remember the this is
the thing about me is
whenever i make something that i'm
really proud of or i'm really happy with
or i love the way it came together i
watch it i do this
this thing that i'm doing anyway you
could ask amy after the trailer came out
all i did was and and you'd think i
would be sick of it by then because i
spent so long editing it and then i was
in like the sound mixes for it and then
it came out you know like i started
working on it weeks before it actually
came out
um so you'd think i'd be sick of it
that's not how it works for me for some
reason and i don't know why but i just
love
watching
these things over and over again it's
not all videos i don't watch all my
videos over and over again but whenever
i make something that i know is like an
important thing in my
time on youtube it's like i could watch
it endlessly so i'm going to test that
theory and i'm going to find out when i
get sick of it because i am not sick of
it like
i've only done five times already so
it's not that much anyway let's get some
questions um
let me go to the tippy top here
uh
how long did this take to make from
start to end uh the trailer of the show
the show
i spent like i spent like a year writing
the show
um on and off because i was busy doing
other things as i always am uh filming
it you know
we started filming in
when did we start filming late july
late july late july i think or
july in general
pre-production and stuff like that and
calls for it were all happening for a
while um but this project as a whole
i mean i knew i was gonna make it the
moment like i i knew i was gonna make it
before we even started filming heist you
know i i knew i wanted to do it i had
the idea i didn't have it written but so
uh years trailer um
a little over two weeks i think
um but it be
uh how much bigger in scale is this
project compared to the last two now
that would be spoilers um how did you
design the interior and x tier of the
invincible
um i'll save that question for after the
show comes out um was heist more
challenging to produce or was in space
with markiplier definitely space
by a long shot um you know heist was
challenging because it was my first time
working with like a big crew
and it had a lot of logistical
components to it i had a lot of planning
so it was difficult in that sense in
that i didn't really know um everything
that i was doing as well as i should
have but i learned quickly and it went
smoothly this one though is just
different beasts entirely like when you
have
like all all the visual effects which is
done by uh burning tractor they're
incredible
um when you have this level of vfx and
like all the different pieces coming
together like it's it's difficult to uh
put into words without like
boring you to death but this one's
much more challenging
um buh
did i do my own stunts uh when i
when i could yeah
um i i hit that wall full force as you
see in the trailer i i made my spine
crumple into little bits and all my
bones turned to rubber right it's a very
cool trick that i've got so i'm gonna
say yes
um how big is this space cast again
spoilers
um
did you actually have to be slapped hard
for that one scene
again i'll talk about that after the
show comes out but
what you see is what you get i'll i'll
say that all right we gotta keep going
we're only at five i've been streaming
for too long
give it up for
number six
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well worth
this situation all under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not
come back and crazy always come back and
everything
has to be
[Music]
i'm just going to keep the train rolling
but man
i just still
love it i love it and it's like you know
the music a lot of people talking about
the music again is just like i i that's
always how like i first approach
trailers is like i find the right music
for it because that that like drives
everything um and this one is just great
i think it's called
fantastic
fantastic stuff
fantastic stuff all right give it up for
number seven
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
brace for impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet
captain something is very weird
this situation all under control
it all comes down
it wouldn't do that to bad
[Music]
[Applause]
have you leadership considered that
there is no right answer have we been
here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
and everything
has to begin
[Music]
i don't know what it is about me i still
get chills
i still do like i do
i love it
maybe i'm narcissistic but god it's good
you have no idea you have no idea what's
in store you have no idea you have no
idea
oh
that's good that's good there's a number
there's a number is it oh is it oh is it
not
in the uh the other
did i forget to put did i forget to put
the counter in the other one and let me
uh copy that
no it's there no it's there it's there
it's there sir
all right give it up for number
[Music]
this is your ship correct can't have it
quiet oh yeah that's my ship it's my
pride and joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very weird
this situation all under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake
has to be
[Music]
yeah it's good all right that was number
eight
only 92 left to go when does the show
come out
said right there
please in case you couldn't tell
still fun
still fun
god is fun
oh good stuff good stuff all right you
know what time it is number nine
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something
is situated all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who have trusted you which
means that if i'm seeing it i must be
crazy but i'm not crazy
[Applause]
and everything
has to be
oh man i wonder what i'm gonna get sick
of this i really do wonder one um
because like it's not yet and i've
probably clocked in just personally like
200 something views of this
i've watched this more than anything
i've ever made uh before in my life but
i really do wonder like what's the
number one in this run i'm gonna get
sick of this
because i don't know guess your number
now what it's gonna be all right you oh
we're getting into the double digits
number ten
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chef
impact
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who
[Music]
oh
cause you have no idea you have no you
have no idea
you have no idea you have no idea
ah
still not sick of it still love it gonna
take a little breather to answer some
questions here
um
god just oh man also god there's way
more people here than i thought
i thought by now you guys would have
filtered out but wow you guys are
troopers you're sticking it out with me
and i appreciate that and that's good
for you because when i get to uh
whatever number that i planned for and i
show you guys the secrets um because
like what better way to hide things than
in a what is probably going to be a
six-hour uh livestream archive of what
is supposedly the same thing
[Laughter]
you know what i mean
yeah but i can't make it easy for people
i can't make it easy for people anyway
so gonna share some really cool uh i
won't say anything more about it i won't
say anything more about it but what do
we got
what are the questions um
uh did i design most of the costumes
uh do you have any of the concept
designs uh no that was all pretty much
the costuming department um it's the
same people who did all the heist stuff
and let me tell you they went to town
because basically uh like i gave them
free reign
of the the costuming side of things i
mean obviously i was like there for
approvals and i talked with them about
and i gave them like general guidance
but they had a blast um just with all
the different
things you know going on it's
god man they're incredible big big
preach
uh will there be bloopers yeah probably
um after the show comes out of course
um what inspired you to start the with
markiplier series and what inspired you
to do space specifically uh what is your
personal favorite part of the trailer
i'll catch that next time i'm around um
what inspired it actually was we did we
did a date with markiplier and this is
actually amy and catherine's doing
because they love
interactive stuff and so we were
thinking up we're brainstorming like
yeah let's do something special for
valentine's day um
what if people could go on like a
like a date ah that wouldn't work
because then it it it would have to be
interactive right and then suddenly we
were like oh oh and then i think amy and
katherine are like what if we did make
it interact we could do a whole choose
your adventure or i don't know like it
was
they pushed that um and then everyone
was just like that's a great idea so
then we started doing that um
and really
the the core piece of it
was that it was first person because
it's not like we could have
done a video like you're going on a date
with me if you weren't looking at me
down the barrel of the lens right so we
had to
um
and in a weird way like we learned a ton
with trying to do that uh of the
technical limitations of doing first
person stuff and trying to do like
transitions to different places and
trying to like get from a to b and all
this different stuff that you wouldn't
ordinarily do if you were just like able
to cut and change to a different scene
you know what i mean
um so we learned a lot it was very fun
and i liked it
i didn't automatically want to do a next
another one right away but i i did enjoy
that experience and people seemed to
really enjoy and there was a great
response to it so um
the next opportunity to do one came with
uh
doing one with youtube originals and i
had said
because because this show is free for
those of you who don't know this show
will be free on april 4th when it comes
out it will be free
um but
you know for the longest time you know
when youtube first did it it was youtube
red right before they had the name
change to youtube premium which is still
a thing
but i kept saying like i didn't really
want to put anything behind a paywall
because i didn't like that idea
so why would i do it and i said
hello
my my whole computer seized up for a
moment there i can't lose my count i'll
have to start over
okay i think i'm back i think i'm back
yes
hello hi
so
yes it's free it is very free
uh am i back i'm back okay cool
so
then
you know i just
i mean it's kind of just a natural
progression right the way i do things is
i always try to do
i always try to take it's not
necessarily that i try to do things
bigger because that's that's a that's a
never-ending battle and that goes
nowhere what i try to do is i try to
apply the lessons that i learned
in the last thing that i make to the
next thing that i make and because of
that i get a little more efficient i get
a little more ambitious
because i feel more confident in doing
like different things with it so it it
does
uh it does change up a lot
um
yeah pretty good okay before this whole
stream breaks i'm gonna get back into it
let's keep going it's number eleven
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible i mean it's our ship
actually this is the captain so
technically they are in charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
brace for impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well worth
this situation all under control
it all comes down
it wouldn't do that to bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
and everything
has to be
[Music]
i just get so excited for you guys to
see the whole show that's that's what
really does it for me with watching this
is like and whenever i see it and why i
wanted it to be so good when i made made
it is just like
it had to represent like this show and
the show is so fun and just like oh man
and i i see this a lot this is this
isn't a game
technically per se but it is
interactive
12.
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people
has to be
good stuff good stuff good stuff great
stuff actually if you really think about
it's actually great stuff uh fantastic
stuff
incredible stuff uh stupendous
stupendous stuff
truly spectacular
if you want to watch it without me
bobbing my head in the corner there's a
link in the description go watch the
actual trailer and tell a friend
tell people about it my only objective
from now until the show comes out is to
get as many people watching this trailer
as possible so if you want to assist me
in some way shape or form send this
trailer to someone you know would enjoy
this even if they're not a fan of my
channel like
come on look at the trail the trailer's
fun
if they don't want to watch the show the
trailer though 13 lucky number
[Music]
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chevron
embrace impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well worn this
situation all under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has caused the
lives of people who trusted you which
means that if i'm seeing it i must be
crazy but i'm not crazy
everything is today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
[Music]
wow
that's good stuff i you know i i asked
like when i would get sick of this
trailer from watching it 100 times
but i guess i never considered the
option that i wouldn't get sick of it
but i would go crazy like i would still
like it
but i would lose it after a while so the
new guess is when am i going to lose it
when it when is this gonna drive me
absolutely insane because that's the
real question that we need to ask here
14.
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
[Applause]
have you leadership considered that
there is no right answer have we been
here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to begin
i didn't like how many people i saw
saying i already lost it because i am
as i
said
i'm not crazy
definitely not
but you know what is crazy
is that
you know what's sad actually
we only have 86 more times to watch this
trailer on this stream but you know
what'll make you happier is afterwards
you can watch it as many times as you
like
you can watch it whenever
wherever on any device but you'll make
brad sad if you watch it on your phone
what is that
a 15.
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
brace for impact
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people
has to be
[Music]
oh
i love it i love it
i love it
i love it i just love it
because because i know
all the things
behind it
i love
all the work that everyone has put into
this everyone who like extraordinarily
talented people have put like a lot of
work and it's it's it's an it's like i'm
honored because
it's
it's like they believe in the project
that i'm working on and you know they
say whenever you have people you're
working with you know it's impossible to
make them care as much as you do about
the project you know but i i really
truly believe people cared about this
project the people that were working on
it so it's it's really really really
nice
to know that so many sound people were
willing to do so
so anyway i got a few more questions
here
um
what good advice can you give for
someone who wants to make their own
production
um
well i mean there's the obvious of like
learning before you do trying small and
then growing from there but i think the
biggest thing that helped me
in in this one and it's kind of like a
thing about youtubers in general like
you youtubers that like make a diverse
smorgasbord of content um
is
that i knew
a lot but not all
about every facet of production so like
me being the director right you've heard
of directors movie directors whatever um
it's a title i i'm i'm the guy that is
trying to put what i envision in my head
to life right uh and what helped me a
lot is just knowing
a little bit about every department and
this this goes for everything because
because i filmed everything myself if i
have had to done do anything i started
out just doing it myself so i know
generally lighting generally cameras
generally how vfx work i haven't done
much myself but i know about them thank
you corridor crew for all your very
informational and informative videos and
um i know sound i know generally
costuming i know
very generally makeup
but i know a little bit about every
department and if you are in a
production and you are in charge which i
was
um it really helps to know
what
you're asking people to do
means for their time right because
that's all that's what it all boils down
to is communication and time makes a
project happen right so knowing all
these things that way when i ask
something i'm not asking from a place of
ignorance
and when something is happening i can
know that it's happening because i can
see what they're doing and i'm aware of
like the general thing like
i
i think that is probably the biggest
helper in terms of productions but then
again i like i've made just a few things
but it's helped me in what i do i can't
speak for other productions and stuff
like that
but that's what i'd say give it up for
number 16
what's up it's your boy uh markiplier
here back with another uh trailer
reaction video
now this one's uh youtube originals
interesting
oh that's a nice ship boom yeah pretty
cool
my responsibility weird
whoa
that's pretty cool i like pretty colors
and explosions so when i see them in
trailers i'm happy
a mogus
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer
can you eat
i can't read that fact
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
that was pretty good okay uh you know
i'm gonna give this a uh
official markiplier trailer reacts
oh there's more
thought there would have been some okay
i'll give this an official markiplier
trailers reacts uh like
six out of ten you know
i i was i liked the explosion
in the beginning but i was like man more
explosions
guys if you just like all this story
crap or whatever you know if you just
put it in a trailer trailer is meant for
explosions big loud boom and explosions
so i give it a 6 out of 10.
i'll give it a 6.5 it seemed like you
know it seemed like it was pretty cool
you know pretty cool april 4th i think
it comes out that's less than a month
away oh god i am losing it already
you guys help me
help me
you know would cheer me up number 17.
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it's up to the captain
they
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
and everything
has to be
[Music]
ah man how long
how long have i been streaming
oh an hour
how far into it are we
oh
someone do the math of the this the rate
at which i am watching these and how
extrapolate for how long it's going to
take me to get to the end like that's
what i want to know right now because
i'm starting to realize
i'm starting to realize the consequences
of my actions here
but i ain't no quitter
i
i mean what i say
and i say what i mean when i say number
18.
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
you're in charge
success so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back
and i come back and i always come back
and everything
has to be
[Music]
anyway
three hours and
56 minutes cool
let's just go 48 hours let's just go 48
hours straight that's that's what i'm
here for 48 hours straight
48 hours straight
uh
i'll do this next one uh let's play
style let's play style give it up for uh
19 almost in the
20s
um
this is your ship what do i enjoy most
about making these products acting
editing music etc
um
i mean
i mean none of this really
uh i like those
i like um
i like the whole
like creative process the making of it
is extraordinarily fun it's hard work
but you know it's the kind of hard work
you look back on you're like oh man
those really were the good times you
know because because hard work can seem
daunting at first but you need to
realize that those are the moments
you're really gonna remember you
remember every moment of those days
uh and uh
when it comes down to
like
but what i enjoy the most about this is
actually you guys watching it
that's legitimately that's that's what i
love because i make it and obviously if
it isn't obvious already i make things
that i enjoy
watching
and i think if you're making anything
you should make things that you and
personally enjoy you know
uh but
like
you should have seen me when this
trailer first came out it was just
nothing but
reading comments looking at people
because i've been waiting to tell you
guys i've been waiting i've been i've
been itching for it i've been itching
for it and it's just
man
the response um
i talked about it on the member mixer
i think um
and everything
has to begin
um i totally forgot what i was saying uh
oh there's just like
talk about this all the time uh i feel
like i do anyway but there's this
japanese breakfast club uh song called
paprika uh
basically the song is about the feeling
of people enjoying what you create
that's a summary of it it's more than
that but you know just like
there's a very special feeling about
people
enjoying what you make and like having
that be a part of it is is just like
that's that's everything for me that's
everything for me
we're in the 20s
we're in the 20s
[Music]
uh we're in the 20s
yeah so it's like that's what i like
about it the editing of it you know
um they are in charge
like it's work but it's beautiful to see
it come together you know um the acting
of it is like this
that's part of what needs to be there
it's like an ingredient right you got
these ingredients that you gotta throw
in there and it's just like
i don't not enjoy those but i wouldn't
say that all those are
my passion by themselves it's a
culmination
warning large object on collision course
with ship
impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well worn out
this situation all under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
hey sorry i just i had to because like
oh man i can't i can't interrupt that i
can't interrupt that don't worry i will
interrupt it in the future i imagine but
now that we're in the uh
no 20 we only we only have 80 left
we only have 80 times left that we get
to watch this
we got 80 times
heartbreaking heartbreaking
heartbreaking
heartbreaking
yeah
the head is throwing me off hey
i mean it's our ship actually
okay
i don't know what to say about that
um
[Music]
what do i enjoy more writing or acting
i don't know man
it's all part of it i could i if you
asked me to pick those little pieces out
of it it's not really
like if one more thing
it never even comes into the equation
there are just certain things that are
like you gotta do
um
because my my my eye is on the big
the final product the final project is
all i consider and think about that's
what i already have in my head so like
seeing that come to life later
is
all that matters to me um and that's all
i'm thinking about
so
you know it's
it's really just like
not a consideration really
yeah
what flavored cookie
i think it's chocolate chip
the important questions here the
important questions
um
[Music]
i'll talk about the actual like
nuances of how things are made
afterwards when it comes out
am i gonna do that laughing already
watch i don't know i get stuck in habits
i get stuck in loops i don't know
it just happens that way
did i actually transform myself into all
the animals at the end of the trailer
need to know for science oh yeah yeah
absolutely yeah 100 100 i did
okay
i'm going into zen mode
i'm going into zen mode
do not interrupt my experience during
zen mode
this is about the
essence of the project itself this is
about the essence of it so i'm going to
subsume subsume
consume
the essence of it
crank your volume
it's going to be good 22.
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well working
this situation all under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
i'm in zen mode
good it's good i don't know why the
number was flying away there
you stay put 22
you stay put
you stay put
why is it moving there too
why is it it's all sliding over i didn't
give it enough space or something i have
no idea anyway
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
impact
it's up to the captain
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost a lot of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything is today
and i come back and i always come back
and everything
has to be
oh
oh
still good still love it
still love it
still fantastic still love it
oh
goddamn
goddamn
beautiful
for those of you who are just joining me
i'm watching the trailer to in space
with markiplier my upcoming youtube
originals and ironically
i think the last youtube originals
apparently
two one 100 times and we're up to
24. this is your who's shaking and
crying rnn that's my ship it's my pride
and joy
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
impact
it's up to the captain
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back
and i come back and i always come back
and everything
has to be
oh
we're almost a quarter of the way
through
we're almost a quarter of the way
through
who's here with me for the long haul
who's gonna be with me when i go from 99
to 100 and then from 100 to 200 and then
from 200 to 300 who's possibly gonna
stick here with me
who's up for it
all week
all week
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with sharepoint
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to be
a thousand
a thousand times someone math out at my
current rate of speed
how long
how long
it would take me to watch this a
thousand times
i don't want to hear about a thousand
when i'm only 25 in
i'll watch it a thousand times leading
up to it you know i'll get there i'll
get there i'll get there i'll get there
i'll get there i always love
the corner of my eye i'll see someone in
chat like i just popped in what's going
on here and i just think the next
thought is dear lord
oh god
26.
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
braced impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very weird
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and they come back
and i always come back and everything
has to be
oh
whoa i don't know what i just said i'm
gonna put a pole
out there
just because i'm curious i'm curious i'm
gonna let that run until uh until uh we
get to the next break here but also i
should have renamed this enjoying the
same video because i'm still enjoying it
i'm still enjoying it guys i'm still
enjoying it
so uh
i mean what's not to enjoy
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chevron
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well seen at
this situation all under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not crazy
everything that's today
come back can i go and they come back
and i always come back and everything
has to be
wow
hey
good good stuff good good stuff guys
what did the poll say oh
87 of you believe in me
is that because you know i'm crazy or uh
are you trying to insult me
also the the 13 who think i can
pitiful
i'm putting in a little request here
and you know what time it is what number
was that i'm not even counting the
numbers i'm just enjoying this so much
i can't believe this this is your shift
i think i'm not gonna make it oh yeah
that's my ship it's my pride and joy the
invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear there's one more thing blows up
on my ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
race impact
it's up to the captain
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything is today
come back
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to be
wow ah still good still good it is
number 28 right it is 28 right or did i
did i like accidentally double press it
it's 28 right
i'll deduct a number hey i'll watch
again you know
i'll keep going the party train don't
stop
i'm gonna make it stop at 69 just do
that yeah it's 28. it's definitely 28.
there are people here who have been uh
with me this whole time and i don't know
how it would have not been that anyway
considering i'm pressing just one button
here unless it's broken
29
yeah
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
[Music]
wow
good stuff it comes out april 4th you
know what blows my mind
there are things in this trailer
that
i've seen no one mentioned
no one talk about
like no one even asks a question about
it
and it's so
is so clear
it's so right there but no one's talked
i've seen no one talk about it and i've
been looking i've been looking but i
can't believe that this thing has gone
over people's heads like it has
so oh sorry
what am i doing talking i can let the
trailer do the dogging
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very weird
this situation all under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake
who trusted you which means that if i'm
seeing it i must be crazy but i'm not
crazy
everything has today
come back
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to begin
[Music]
good stuff i think what it is
like i don't think any of you guys saw
it that time through either it's one of
those things
where everyone's always looking
for something to be hidden
but when you stick it
right in people's faces
they don't notice the thing it's the
core principle called hidden in plain
sight brought to you by cloak bran
cloak cloak bran
no it really it really is like i'm not
lying i'm not just saying this to be
like
oh look closely you'll find something
it's just like i just can't believe no
one's talking about it
i've seen no one talking about it anyway
if anyone
no it's true everyone always looks let
me break this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
brace impact
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to be
[Music]
amy
you can come in
come get it i'm not wearing pants
i have no pants
i have no pants
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
what better way
to watch a great video and have some
popcorn in your hand
hey amy
i need some water
could i
please
good old water
keep going keep it going
did you see the the thing
the secret
lies go again oh yeah that's my ship
it's my pride and joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chef
brace impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is there
all under control
it all comes down i wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today government come
back
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to begin
oh
not no no no
no
no
you're so focused
on trying to find something that's wrong
you're not focused on what's really
there
you know what i mean i want
one of you will ask the right question i
imagine
someday
maybe on watch 80.
or did you ever think
that these aren't the same video i'm
showing you
everything about that
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy be invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the cap so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well seen at
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
wow
have you ever heard the story
about uh
a frog in a pot of slowly boiling water
they say that the frog won't hop out you
know why
because the temperature
is changing so slowly
that the frog doesn't notice it
now you might think that's silly
probably is silly
probably
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chef
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake
everything has to be
all right someone must have got it that
time someone must i didn't see it
i would have thought
people would have got on by now
all right if you guys don't get it on
this next one
i will uh
i'll give you a hint i'm not just gonna
reveal it all
i'll give you a hint
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
race impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well done this
situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go
and everything
has to be
wow
ah everyone's so focused on what's like
you're so focused on what's
hidden or what's wrong you're missing
the point i'll tell you it's it's it's
not speeding up that's a phantom in your
head you might think it's speeding up
because you've seen it already
i would know if it was speeding up it's
not speeding up
sad to say that to say
um okay hint um
okay this is a hint
what did i say
what did i say
about uh
no that would i would give it away i'll
give it right away i'd give it right
away
i could i'll i'll give it a more general
hand we'll we'll see how it goes this
time and like it has nothing to do
with any
inanimate object
in the trailer okay that's your hit
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet
captain something is very weird
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad
[Music]
[Applause]
ever leadership that there is no right
answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything
[Applause]
and everything
has to begin
[Music]
all right that must have given it away
come on
come on oh to answer the question
yes
you
are the captain
i i can't believe some people are still
not getting that
literally there's a shot there where i
grab your hand and go
captain
and literally everything is about like
so get ready for some responsibility
because uh it's coming april 4th
you haven't found it yet this is your
ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well known
this situation all under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go
[Applause]
and everything
has to be
[Music]
wow
okay so so to be perfectly honest like
most of you guys have caught on to the
general sense of it you know you guys
have got the gist of it
it's just like you guys haven't
identified what it is maybe my
frog in a pot of boiling water was too
on the nose
so like but let's just say
that
it's only really just starting to become
noticeable but
yeah that's all i'll say
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh you're in charge
so
this ship is your
responsibility i swear if one more thing
blows up on my ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
brace for impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet
captain something is there
situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back
and i come back and i always come back
and everything
has to
[Music]
oh
well ain't one of you clever
ain't one of you real clever
i only saw it for a second
i haven't seen it yet
since
but uh
that was a pretty good guess
look pretty good guess
so someone's got it someone's got it
someone's got it
i'll i'll let you mull it you debate
amongst yourself for a moment we'll get
to 40.
when we get to 40 i'll uh
i'll see if more people get there
this is your ship correct
oh
yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shareholders
for impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet captain
something is very well worth
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad
[Music]
leadership have you ever considered that
there is no right answer have we been
here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who have trusted you which
means that if i'm seeing it i must be
crazy but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
wow
people are catching on people are
getting there not everyone people are
really pushing their own ideas it's
really hard
there's one person i just keep like yes
it must be this is i got it it's like
i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
let's go one more round i said at 40
i'll talk about it in full so we'll give
it one more go for the last minute for
people to catch on
with what's going on
and then
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back
and i come back and i always come back
and everything
has to be
[Music]
all right
not as many people got there it seems
like that was the uh
least popular idea in the pack in fact i
see it less and less this time around
okay hang on i got
popcorn in my mouth
i was actually surprised when i saw it
was like three watches ago i saw the
comment
oh but should i just say it out loud
should i just ruin the fun
we've got 60 more watches to go if i
spoil it all now
it's gonna be meaningless
you know what i mean
you know what i mean
all right let's do one more
one more one more i i don't want to ruin
it right now
we're having a good time
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chevron
it's up to the captain
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
wow
all right
it's starting to become more obvious now
so i think we can talk openly about it
hang on i keep shoveling popcorn in my
gob
all right but when i talk about this i'd
like to assume
i would like to assume
that a lot of you guys who are here
right now
are more of the dedicated people and
won't be just blabbering this to
everybody it's more fun if people like
figure it out for themselves i'm going
to just put i'm to keep the counter
going and to save myself i'm going to
keep it going but this way i can like
point it out uh in this next one so i'm
going to play through it but i'm going
to keep the volume down so i can talk so
like i said
i i figure that you guys
are the more dedicated ones
so you are able to keep
a secret i know there's probably like
not gonna be everyone's just gonna like
say it out
but they're you know
i i get that there will be some i can't
control that but i'm just gonna be
like as open as possible here
it's not here yet uh so we're good um
i'm just gonna be as open as possible
when i'm telling you this because like
with with this show
like just
oh how do i say this without
giving it all
uh
like i got to be careful with what i say
here
um
so the thing about like the show is that
i want it to be special for as many
people as possible okay i see i see my
lips are sealed i get that i get that
um
how do i say this i don't even know
hey we're at 42.
so
like i was saying before about it it
being like
so many people are focused on what's
wrong and not well i don't i don't want
to say like what's right
but it's just like
everyone's looking for
like a mistake or something a a little
oopsy poopsy you know they're but
they're not seeing like what's directly
being presented to them
i have missed it
all right you know uh
i gotta go back
i could go back around
one more time
48 58 more times
hold on
hold on
it's not a long trailer
okay hold on you guys keep a secret this
time i'll keep
let me get my popcorn in now so i don't
start shoveling it in midway
hold on
okay okay
all right
same disclaimer yada yada
keep it between us now let's just be
quiet
and then when it when we get there
that way i'm not blabbering in the
middle of it
it actually is important to hear this
ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
okay hold on pay attention
okay pay
attention collision course
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is fair
pay attention it's coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer
pay attention it's coming up
pay attention is coming up
did you get it
did you get it
how could you not get
i made it so clear
i told you pay attention it's coming up
how could you not see it
how did you not say it
all right let's go again
this time
can you at least like
i don't know try to pay attention you
know you know i i don't have to hold i
thought you guys might have been a
little bit more intelligent you know
given that this is like
this is coming out on my 10-year
anniversary i've been making videos for
a while so i think you would understand
like i know i'm really smart and all but
i would have thought you'd have been
able to keep up so far
i guess not now i'm gonna do this again
full volume and you pay attention it's
coming up this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible i mean it's our ship
actually this is the captain so
technically they are in charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well we seem
to have this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer
[Music]
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
wow
okay
no gag
all right i think we're all on the same
page now
i think we're all on the same page cat's
out of the bag
no hiding it anymore it's too obvious
there's no way anyone would uh be able
to miss it
ain't that the truth
i think it was
i think it was on the second watch after
i said
i think it was after i said the frog in
a pot of boiling water
that i saw the answer
and it was so uh so i was i was stunned
that it was that early
i'm gonna say it i'm gonna say it right
now um like
and i i said the frog thing like
the second time
and then i saw this comment
i'll just uh hey let me remember what
the comment said because
i think it was um
yeah
okay i'm quoting right now
it's not really changing mark's just
messing with us end quote
and i took offense to that
let's go again and check for that secret
i i i i looked back and i saw another
one that was just like
this was like after that one it was just
like is this
a trick and then but you guys got so
into it you guys got so into
oh now everyone now everyone's gonna be
like i knew it i knew that i knew he was
messing with us the whole time
no you did not you're so eager for a
secret that you overlook everything like
i said it's like i said from the
beginning
you're trying to look for what's hidden
and not what's in front of you which is
that i've done this so many times i've
tricked you so many times and yet you
keep falling for it
you fall for it over and over i i just
noticed the poll is still up
for will i make it to 100 and it yes
just went down one percent
i trick you guys so much
so much
and every single time
god can you imagine the work that i
would have to do to make a hundred
different versions of the trailer this
trailer barely got up 45 minutes before
it was supposed to you know that
premiere got set up a weird number of
minutes before it went up that's because
the trailer was delivered to my hand
from the finished sound edit and
coloring
45 minutes before
it was supposed to go up
you think i got time to make a hundred
versions of the a trailer
for a stream or or or is the more
logical answer is i'm an idiot
but i'm a smart idiot
and i need to figure out how to trick
people into joining me to watch this a
hundred times
what's the more likely scenario here
what do you think could possibly be the
correct answer here
no no no
i know what i'm doing the whole time i
know
there's so many people that are like oh
i knew it yeah but when did you know it
did you know it before the last watch or
did you do it 10 watches ago
oh man but i will say i will say when i
was first talking about that i actually
there there literally was something that
i was surprised people weren't talking
about
but it wasn't like a big
huge revealing secret i was just kind of
like oh people are so focused on x
they're not seeing why and that's what i
was talking about and also
popcorn
um and also
if i did
do the hundred different videos
i wouldn't have time for that right
there's no way would have taken me too
long
but i do have time to change
one of them
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shareholder
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
wow
see now you guys don't know what to
believe
because it's totally reasonable that i
could change one of these but you've
been tricked before
so i see a lot of people saying you
won't get tricked again
which is exactly the scenario i would
like people to be in
for when
the different one comes up
but i could be lying
because i've done it before
i've tricked you so many times you don't
want to be tricked again
but you don't want to miss out either
you could be the only one that sticks it
up
well
believe what you want to believe
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
[Music]
wow
all right i'll do a poll
i'll do a poll
because because i i will perfectly i get
that you don't trust me
that one of these has changed i
understand that now
and i already understood that would
happen
uh
when i planned it
when i planned it
when i planned it but i'll run a poll
i'm gonna make it a simple one we got
that last poll will i make do a hundred
i think we all know that we're getting
there
end poll of the last one okay
okay
is this a trick and i'll let it run
until the next one's done
is it a trick yes or no
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
good warning large object on collision
course with shell
brace for impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well we need
to have this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost a lot of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
and everything
has to be
[Music]
wow
you know uh that number
that said yes it was a trick started out
a lot higher and then as the trailer
played it got lower i think it started
at uh 70 and now it's down to 63
so
i get it
i get it
the majority of you think it's a trick
which would be the safe bet absolutely
absolutely it would be
i have nothing else to say absolutely
that would be the safe bet 100 100
that would be the safe bet
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it wouldn't do that to bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back
and i always come back and everything
has
[Music]
oh
all right
you know it's really funny
i uh
no yes no yes no yes because because
it's
i love
surprising people
if if people believe that like my
favorite thing is tricking people it's
not
it's surprising people which is similar
to tricking
so like if you say it's not a trick
and if it's not a trick you would be
surprised but what is a surprise is that
the next video
is the
halfway point between the start of this
stream and my goal
of 100 watches and i have been seeing
some people and like the moderators
bless your heart saying the trailer
still hasn't gotten old yet who here has
been here since the beginning of the
stream and is still watching
all of these
which i
i love you thank you so much
why not
no
no no
no no because anything i say now will
just like you'll hold it against me so
it's best if i just don't say anything
at all from here on out but this is the
50th watch and if there was one to watch
it would be this one
yeah i've said too much
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet captain
something is very well worth this
situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
you ever considered that there is no
right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
[Applause]
and everything
has to be
[Music]
well [ __ ] uh
that wasn't the right one
god damn it can we redo number 50 again
could we redo it
god damn it
ah
god damn it
uh okay
all that build up for the beautiful
number 50.
um i have can i do i'm going to do some
technical fixing i'm going to do some
technical fixing
can i just do some technical fixing real
quick uh cause that
that shouldn't have been
if you're not crazy that would look just
like the other one and you're right
hold on
hold on
hand i get a um
oh my god
i
don't think i have the hard drive in
here hold on
don't look at the man behind the curtain
this was all just so mysterious just a
second ago you didn't know what to trust
now's the part where i'm just an idiot
so uh hold on and i'll be an idiot right
back again uh just give me give me two
seconds uh give me give me two minutes
i'm gonna play it again what i'll do is
i'll pull up the video on my phone as i
go do this mysterious thing that i'm
about to do and i'll watch it there and
then you can you know that i'm
gonna hold on
oh
how the hell oh my god
i hope i don't have to stop the stream
but it's okay it's okay everything's
fine everything's fine i'll be right
back don't worry about anything it's
just totally fine
don't worry
all is good
kinda
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost
[Applause]
has to be
okay i'm back
hold on
all right i gotta i gotta do some uh
uh stuff and things i got to do stuff
and things i got stuff and things and i
got to do stuff
and things
hold on
hold on
hold
hold
hold yourself
just to keep the counter going i'm going
to go it again
um
yep
hold on one second
correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my private
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object
i wasn't even thinking of trying to get
this sorted there's uh if you haven't
picked up on it there's uh
i had a special surprise made for this
stream and i was going to put it
i am going to watch it 100 times but
hold on
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and they come back
and i always come back and everything
has to be
wow
i'm just hoping that i don't have to
stop screaming
to fix it
because
i'm sorry you can hear me i'm just
hoping that i don't have to stop
streaming to fix it because the way i
have this setup is like my
the reason it's a problem is because i
built a very special macro
to
have this counter increase
switch scenes and go play that video
and it was supposed to do something else
it was supposed to it was it was
supposed to do something else
hold on i like it
i let go i like how
my pride and joy
when i i mean it's our ship actually
this is the cabin you know what anything
i say will just uh
paint a bigger
target on my back
but
this ship is your responsibility
no one believes me that's fine i get it
i understand i understand now hold on
i have to
figure out how to do this
warning large object on collision course
with
all under control
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not
back crazy everything
has to be
nope not that
i know this is thrilling content
not saying watching this video a hundred
times with thrilling content but uh
there's nothing more there's nothing
more dry than tech support with
markiplier
i i spent like
before before we got started here i
spent like
an hour and a half
trying to get this thing to work
perfectly i had to like go into
uh documentation
like just try i thought it would be like
a five minute thing
because i had a very simple solution for
it and
no
would not work properly
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
it's up to the captain
okay i'm just gonna have to
be not fancy about it
i'm just going to
plop this in
right on top of everything else
and if it breaks
i'm at 54 right now so we're going to
make 55.
55 what an important number
and then
if it breaks everything else just please
remember it was 55 so that it when
everything goes to crap i can come back
to that that would be the ideal thing
that would be ideal please remember this
next one is 55
if the counter disappears
this is 55.
this next one will be 55
and then
i'm not gonna try to like
waste more time trying to get it to be
perfect
right okay nope not that
all right
oh the big mystery whoa am i tricking
you am i not tricky who's like all
perfect
anyway
pay attention very closely to this one
and
[Music]
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very important that
this situation all under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who have trusted you which
means that if i'm seeing it i must be
crazy but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
[Music]
oh
okay finally there
oh big surprise okay
so
uh like i said before
don't tell anyone about that one
um i know the word's gonna get out about
it but just like keep it to yourselves
as best you can
thank you for sticking with me through
the stream to get to this i know it's
been a long time uh but you know i like
i just love
well i mean i love the idea of like
surprising you with it i would have
liked to have uh to happen organically
but uh yeah so
like the basic principle that i wanted
to have here
is just that like
i spent all that time
getting that new one there
and you still think i tricked you
i literally showed you just now a
completely different well okay it's not
completely different i didn't have time
to make a new one
i can show it to you again
i can show i'll go frame by frame if you
need me to hold your hand like that i'll
show it to you again i'll show it again
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
brace for impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is there
situation all under control
it all comes down i wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means
and everything
has to be
oh
it's not the same some people saw it
that time thank you some people
like it's it's so funny because people
will analyze like they'll go into those
uh like the the glitches in that scene
and they'll go frame by frame looking in
the glitches oh there's got to be a
hidden secret in there somewhere but
when like an entire scene is changed
and you've watched this
50 some odd times and people still go
is the same it's the same it's the same
why do i even bother
why do i even bother
if it's just gonna be a constant thing
of oh no he's tricking us
like specifically i'm literally going to
tell you specifically where it was
different it is after
i am in that hallway and i go if one
more thing blows up on my ship i'm gonna
lose it
there
in fact it's coming up here let me
let me make it obvious for you
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
it wouldn't do that to bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back
and i always come back and everything
has to
[Music]
thank you
thank you
it's pretty obvious when i point it out
isn't it
good okay you guys got it yeah um
that don't worry that doesn't like that
doesn't like reveal
any spoilers about the show itself
um i just wanted to like do something
special for you so yeah
look if you didn't see it i like i i
can't help you there are so many people
in chat that saw it ask them
get them to get you a screenshot i'm
going to go back to the normal trailer
now uh if you missed it i apologize the
stream will be done in
two something hours and then we can get
back uh let me just change this over
uh
one second i had to just slap that in
there
yes i i saw some people like
recorded it so
but don't
don't
you made a promise before this that you
would not go spreading that around
everywhere we had an agreement that that
was just between us
if someone
like dms
someone for that that's fine but don't
go posting it because that's just
between us that was just for us who are
here
for the 100 watch party
everyone's like sorry
yes
yes
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
brace for impact
it's up to the captain
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
and everything
has to be
wow
cool
i still love this trailer it's still
going by you're not crazy that is not
the different one this is the normal one
we are back to the normal one i still
have to do the commitment of 100 watches
this one had no changes this one was
fine
you're not insane you're not crazy
this one is the same
100 percent exactly the same no [ __ ]
this one is the same
and i have to crank these numbers out
now
this is your ship it's like it's like i
can literally tell you there's like it's
it's like you're reverse psychology me
because i like i'll trick you and then
you're like you don't believe me and
then i'm like this is exactly the same
and it's like you're lying still i'm
like no this one this is the original
this is what it was
this is the trailer it's a very good
trailer i i mean watch it frame by frame
it's very good
but this one is the same
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with sharepoint
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
[Music]
listen guys
uh
i can't trick you if there's no trick
you know what i mean
everything is completely normal
everything is back to normal there
there's not going to be any other
differences
from here to the end
there's not going to be anything that's
off there's no more surprises the
surprise occurred and then now we're
just going to sit and everything is
going to be normal
everything will be normal
i've got nothing else planned
and
there will be no surprises
we
are
a place of honesty
and when i say
that there are no more surprises i'm
telling you
there aren't
this is the same video that's my ship
it's my pride and joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet captain
something is very well we need to have
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad
leadership have you ever considered that
there is no right answer have we been
here
before every mistake has cost a lot of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
and everything
has to be
i don't know how to tell you this any
differently uh cause i'm
like i'm literally saying
that there's
there's no differences
from here to the end of the stream this
video this video is the same this video
is exactly the same
100
this video is the same
and nothing else
uh from
like till the end of the stream will be
different
there's no more surprises i have
surprised all my surprises uh tricked
all the tricks and there's no more
tricks
okay cool
61.
61.
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shareholders
for impact
it's up to the captain
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
ah pretty good pretty good pretty good
still like it still love it
still love it i don't still love
everyone accusing me of things
in chat okay
okay
i
have nothing else
to give you what would what could i have
to offer you more
than what i have already
nothing i'll make another poll i'll make
another poll
um
are there any more secrets yes no
should be pretty easy should be pretty
simple should be pretty straightforward
answer
to the post yeah there it is
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well we need
to have this situation all under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and they come back
and i always come back and everything
has to be
wow
guys i uh
i don't know how to say there's 66 of
you that think that there is a secret
and i can say
with full confidence that there are no
more secrets
and this like this video is exactly the
same 100
and there's nothing that's going to
change
about that in the future
nothing
so i'm just gonna keep trucking
i'm gonna keep going until i get to a
hundred
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
brace for impact
it's up to the
captain haven't let us down yet
captain something is very weird
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
everyone they can cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and they come back
and i always come back and everything
has to be
[Music]
ah don't think i haven't noticed that
the poll number keeps going up
more people think that there are secrets
uh
it's at 69 68 percent right now
and they're
like there's nothing else happening
you know
it's gonna be perfectly normal
and
that's the end of it
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embrace impact
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people
and everything
has
[Music]
oh
yeah
anyway good trailer guys good trailers
good trailer
uh
nothing to do now till the end of the
stream but just keep watching
nothing to do
cool
cool
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it's up to the captain
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who have trusted you which
means that if i'm seeing it i must be
crazy
and everything
has to begin
wow
ah good one good one 65 65
[Music]
only uh
34
uh 35 left to go 34 35 30 something like
that something like that
ah
yeah
same old trailer same old trailer
same old boring old trailer nothing
different nothing changing about it
for the rest of the stream
nothing nothing though
nothing
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with sharepoint
it all comes down
it wouldn't do that to bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
wow
another good viewing of another good
trailer really hits hard you know on the
66th time
something about the 60s really
make you feel it you really really
appreciate the grandeur of it then
yeah
i'll be real sad when uh
and these are over
the 60s
yeah what a tragedy it'll be
oh what a tragedy one more time
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
race impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well working
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have
[Music]
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not crazy
everything
and i come is and i always come back and
everything
has to be
another incredible viewing of another
incredible trailer ah 67
damn
how time flies how time flies this is
how time flies
why not shall we do uh another viewing
another one why not shall we do another
one why not shall we do
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
oh
68
we're coming up on uh
the funny number
uh not that i got anything special
planned
all right oh man i guess we just gotta
go around the bend again
and
we'll
just
have a
it's gonna be perfectly normal
everything is exactly the same there's
nothing different
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
brace for impact
it's up to the captain
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
and everything
has to be
[Music]
wow
nice
very nice
i that one was very special for me
i if you guys have noticed
i was uh like
looking away from the camera
typing yada yada for a while now
i've been uh every time i've done that
when in my past uh tricks that i've
played on you and i have been and i
still have been and some of you still
uh forget that i trick you all the time
and you still tricked there are no more
secrets
and there wasn't even a secret then
i was typing in discord with um the
moderators here who are in chat with you
right now and uh they presented this
idea so this is really their own doing
but they presented this idea that for
the 69th uh run through this so i better
just play this so i can get my counter
up uh but the volume for my 69th run
through this
they wanted me to switch it out to the
heist with markiplier trailer would have
been a great prank it would have been
great
i had them hook line and sinker i was
like quick guys quick you got to
download it for me i can't download it
right now you got to download and put it
in the discord i got to get the file and
add i just got to drop it off it was a
pain in the ass when i set it up that
wasn't a lie it was like
they bought it
they bought it
they bought it all
the moderators
i got them
i got you
i'm not typing yet
uh
oh man it's the little things it's the
little things it's the little things you
guys don't even understand you guys
don't even understand i mean you were
subjected to the same torment that i put
them through a little bit ago but now
it's happening to someone else so it's
even it's it's fine it's it's fine
[Laughter]
anyway there's totally a secret just
waiting for it
god if there was one and there's not and
i'm dead serious about that there's no
differences why would i do that or do i
or am i or is they or is we maybe there
is maybe not or
like i said the first trick
isn't the more likely scenario that i'm
dr i'm going insane and i'm dragging you
all down with me
on this mind-numbing journey through 100
watches of admittedly a very good
trailer yeah i asked at the beginning of
this when do you think i would go insane
i was already insane that's the answer
you are all wrong
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i i swear
there are no more tricks
there are absolutely no more tricks
and there's nothing else to do but watch
this fantastic trailer
which we have just watched 70 times
which means that we only have 30 watches
to go
which is great which is fantastic and
let's just keep them trucking here let's
just keep them trucking
i'm gonna make another pole
i'm gonna make another bowl
i'm gonna make another poll look if you
guys can trick me back
if you guys have the intelligence i'm
speaking to the moderators specifically
i'm speaking to the mods you guys in the
general audience this isn't for you but
if you guys are smart enough to trick me
back
i welcome it i welcome it it's totally
fine
who is here from the beginning of this
ordeal who is here from the very
beginning of this adventure
oh i'll go ahead and tell you guys all
the tricks so when i s when i turn my
camera off this is when i started uh sex
uh talking to the mods when i turned my
camera off to do some technical
maintenance that was my bathroom break
so that was very convenient um there was
nothing different in any of the trailers
at any time there hasn't been nothing
different you have just been watching it
70 times in a row so your brain is
playing tricks on you and
additionally after the 50th when i said
something was different and everyone in
chat believed that there's something is
different those are the people that were
onto me and they were in turn trying to
trick you i'm talking to those of you
who have been tricked this whole time
and have picked the wrong answer on the
polls
that's all and then then i moved on to
tormenting the moderators
and now
there is nothing else all that's left is
you
me
and 29 run throughs of this trailer
and that's it
that's it see you would you shouldn't
have trust issues
because
you should know
why would i tell you
anything i didn't want you to know
why would i give you
anything the show is coming out april 4
and that's why i pre-recorded this
entire live stream because i knew
that you would believe every word of it
and i wouldn't have to do anything
god
like i know when i'm gonna get you so
good
that i literally recorded this whole
stream ahead of time
this isn't live
i'm not even live right now
i am literally
out at dinner
i'm not even here
they are in charge
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
oh you're still here oh good i was
hoping so well maybe there's people here
well maybe there's not i swear if one
more thing blows up on my ship i'm gonna
lose it
still here
all right
you do know there is a technology i'm
just kidding there's this is totally
alive i'm not i'm i'm absolutely 100
aware that this is live and also haha
very funny muted but also
i tricked myself with that all the time
so i know exactly when i haven't been
muted
so uh
oh it's a good prank guys nice good
prank
guys it's good prank
how did i do a poll ah
pre-scheduled things
see the problem with things like this is
you all can't agree because there will
be people that always ask questions
about things that i am currently saying
no matter what i do
so there's no way that you could pop
because anytime someone says there's lag
they'll be like there's no lag i'm not
getting anything
oh he's muted he's not muted for me you
know you'll give yourself away every
time you'll give yourself away every
time
behind me oh god oh you got me
oh
man
how many times have we watched through
this how many times is this 72
all right cool
good good good good good
all right let's get back into zen mode
we got we got work to do guys if you
didn't if you didn't remember
there's a purpose to this and this is to
share the word of this trailer far and
wide now i know i've tricked you before
but this time you got to believe me
no no no this is a personal challenge
and we're almost all the way through it
we gotta see it to the end guys
we gotta see it to the end no matter
what
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible i mean it's our ship
actually did someone just say there's a
camera in one of my shots do you know
how we filmed this i hope it's a joke
because it's very funny oh like that's a
good one
there was only ever one camera and you
the captain
are the camera
if one more thing blows up on my ship
i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is there we don't want
to have this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not crazy
everything has to end goldman come back
and everything
has to be
wow
you know i'm still not tired of it i i
honestly truly am not tired of
of the trailer it is
like i've watched this now
73 times today
plus
however many times i watched it during
the editing process
i think this is a really good trailer
i'm going to be egotistical for a second
just now never any other time and i'm
gonna say that like this is the best
trailer that i've made
and and i owe it a lot to the obviously
i didn't put the effects in there you
know i just cut it up but just like i am
super proud of this trailer i think it's
very good i think that anybody watching
who who who likes this kind of content
or movies or whatever they saw this
trailer in theaters they wouldn't think
anything of it they'd be interested in
it i'd like to think anyway
and what i think says say go
man all this deceiving people takes it
out of you oh yeah that's my [ __ ] it's
my pride and joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with sharepoint
embrace impact
it's up to the captain
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
and everything
has to be
wow
yes i'm still watching of course i'm
still watching no honestly i'm not tired
of it yet i really am not i it's kind of
crazy i i thought i would be at this
point i really thought i would be but no
i i think it's a great trailer
and uh like i said i just can't wait for
you guys to see the actual show um i
will and this is not a lie
i'm dead serious and i know no one will
believe me but at the end of the stream
i will show you some behind the scenes
pictures that no one else has seen uh i
think it'd just be cool to look like on
how
we film some of it i'll give you like
one or two i'll give you whatever amy
approves to show you
and maybe i should have asked beforehand
75
75
correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chef
impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet
captain something is very weird
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has caused the lies of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
and everything
has to be
oh
she's a beaut
she's a mute
she's a mute
no no no no i i i
completely legitimately openly am not
deceiving you uh i know that we have a
collection of behind-the-scenes photos
um that we're actually going to start uh
putting out there anyway uh because we
got all the the the cast
has like individual like folders of
photos and stuff like that um that we're
gonna send out so that they can post you
know whatever and
help promote the show but also just like
uh i gotta double check on what's kosher
this is yours
we're almost like three quarters of the
way through we're over three quarters of
the way
the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh i'm still here you're in charge 100
watchers
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chevron
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well done this
situation
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
[Music]
never gets old i've submitted the formal
request for uh
behind the scenes stuff oh
no
okay
have you showed anyone the trailer yet
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy have you shared that i mean it's our
ship you know
when it's coming out
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
embrace impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet captain
something is very weird we don't want to
keep that situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
you ever considered that there is no
right answer have we been here
before
every mistake
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
[Music]
oh
a good one
sorry just texting people what are we at
77
someone tell wade someone tell wade
you know he's lord minion 7-7
everyone knows that everyone knows who
he is
everyone knows who he be tell him we're
on the 77th one he probably feels it
he probably feels it in his bones 78
it's over the moment's over too late too
warn them this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chef
under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
and everything
has to be
wow
still good still good april 4th april
4th
i love it love it love it love it
oh
wow
really
i just got a notification
that said
we have detected copyrighted music in
your live stream your three may be
blocked or not available and i'm saying
the [ __ ] you talking about
there's only one song that's been
playing this whole time
and it's a banger and also i have a
license for it for the show
so uh
i literally just got a heads up we
detected copyrighted audio on your
stream oh good catch good catch there
youtube only took you 78 tries before
you found that one i'm gonna keep
trucking
man those those unmuted uh comments
might actually be right a little bit
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision
situation all under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who have trusted you which
means that if i'm seeing it i must be
crazy but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and they come back
and i always come back and everything
has to be
we're doing good guys
we're doing good
we're staying strong
we're staying strong
we're doing it
we're doing it we can make it only 21
left to go remember when we had 21 at
the beginning of this it was like it was
nothing
i think it took me an hour
[Music]
and joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well worn out
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost a lot of people
who trusted you which means that if i'm
seeing it i must be crazy but i'm not
crazy
and everything
has to be
another excellent watch through
another banger of a video
and we only have 20 more to go
are you feeling it now
[Music]
almost there almost there i don't know
why i'm so tired
i got decent enough sleep last night
i don't know why
but
i will persevere
because that's what i do
that's what i'm all about
that's what i do and why i do it
so let's keep going
i might take a bathroom break
i mean i'm gonna mysteriously disappear
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has caused the
lives of people who trusted you which
means that if i'm seeing it i must be
crazy but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back and everything
has to be
wow
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is there
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back
and i come back and i always come back
and everything
has to be
oh
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
[Applause]
warning large object on collision course
with shared
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well worth
this situation all under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
which means that if i'm seeing it i must
be crazy but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and i come back and i
always come back do everything
has to
[Music]
be wow
oh
got him new pole up new pull up guys
who's crying wolf now
all right there's no more tricks
i'm too tired for portraits
but that was 83 so 84 is coming up and
then very soon we will be
right there we'll be right there
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chevron
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well worn out
this situation
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
[Music]
do you know why i have this idea do you
know why i did this not all the tricks
i'm gonna talk about that but this idea
of watching it 100 times
is
there's a fascinating uh
there's a fascinating phenomena
about um
like
uh how youtube works in terms of um
like
this is your [ __ ] getting the word out
to everyone that actually cares about
the stuff that i make so number one
um
the
the super important thing
is just i want as many people as
possible to know about this show just
because i'm super proud of it and all
the people that worked on it did an
incredible job and i think they would
honestly enjoy it that's that's first
and foremost um but i did this
i'm watching this 100 times because
number one it's challenging myself
number two i'm proud of the trailer but
number three
i was just curious of if uh
i don't know i was curious if it
actually would hold up to the test of
time and and honestly
when you do a live stream like people
pop in and out all the time
i guess fine i get it uh like there may
be uh there's like 26 000 people here
but this this
i've had i've got stats here with me
and there's been 1.7 million people that
have at least clicked on this stream and
popped in for a little bit
and the average what time watch time is
three minutes and 41 seconds which is
longer
than uh
the trailer even is so people are
watching it
so uh you know you guys been here and
you guys watching this with me and you
guys putting up with all the nonsenses
just like
it helps get the word out
because like i i already know that you
guys are going to tell people that you
you guys are going to share and all that
stuff and that's great and all but
they're like i have i have like 30
something million subscribers
um and you know of course there are some
like people that subscribe that don't
watch but in all honesty they're
actually reporting of like unique
viewers there's like 20
every month there's like 22 million
unique viewers that watch my stuff
and so it's just people like
popping it out just like they do for
streams
i just got to be here for them to let
them know
that's it and if all i got to do is
watch this
well that's good for me
i watch this 100 times is good for me
i love it anyway just wanted to let you
know like just some monasteries behind
is you know there's there's nothing else
here there's no ulterior to motives here
it's just like i'm proud of the show i
want people to know about it
that's the best way that you could help
like uh help this show in general and
help
you know me to make more cool stuff in
the future is just like
god it's good
that's really good just help spread the
word that's it
that's all
also it's good also it's damn good
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very important that
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad
leadership
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake
of people who have trusted you which
means that if i'm seeing it i must be
crazy but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to be
it was funny yo it's funny
i uh
the week this came out like last friday
right
so the week leading up to that
um
i hadn't been posting a lot of videos
because obviously i was working on this
and there's this general cool thing with
you guys and me is that whenever i'm not
like posting videos
the vast majority of you understand that
i'm working on something big so instead
of getting like considered oh where's
mark you get like either excited or
worried that something's about to happen
you know what i mean and i think that's
just like a really cool dynamic that not
a lot of youtubers can say about their
audience um but it was great because
i don't know how you guys did it but you
guys kind of predicted the day it was
going to come out
i didn't say nothing like you do you
guys do have a sixth sense about it
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
it's 87 bite the bite i made
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chevron
embrace the impact
it's up to the captain
i haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well seen at
this situation all under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and they come back
and i always come back and everything
has to be
wow
who just popped in the stream just now
who just arrived welcome thank you so
much for being here welcome to the uh
most upfront and honest live stream on
youtube today
thanks for joining we've watched this 87
times the exact same trailer over and
over again
running into the end of it here but
we're all happy to be here
we're all happy and excited
we're all excited
give it up for 88.
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shareholders
for impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very important that
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad
[Music]
[Applause]
have you leadership considered that
there is no right answer have we been
here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything
and everything
has to be
wow
beautiful
beautiful
beautiful
beautiful beautiful wonderful beautiful
thank you everybody for being here thank
you for joining me on this journey we've
got 11 more to go
11 beautiful more to go it'll be lovely
so very close to the end
[Music]
and yet so far
bam
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shared
embraced impact
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
everything is today
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to be
oh
we're about to hit 90.
we're about to hit 90.
which you know what that means
10
i still like the trailer but god
my uh my add is starting to make me try
to focus on literally anything else but
this but
you know it's still fun still very fun
occasionally i'll just be like all like
unfocused and then be brought back
because something
bright flashed on the screen i want to
do an experiment this time by now you
guys know this trailer inside and out
right you know it inside and out
completely you know exactly when
everything is i want to do an experiment
uh
don't do it yet
i know me even mentioning this makes it
it happened but don't do it yet
when the slap you know when the slap
occurs
the slap
you know the slap
when that happens
let's use that as a synchronization
point
and if you could hit the like button
when that slap happens
i wonder if we can send so many
simultaneous
signals to youtube we can slap youtube
in the face collectively not enough in a
loving way in a loving way pam
let's see what i would say make 90
special a bit let's make 90 special
we've come a long way
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
under control
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to begin
[Music]
wow
yeah
that was a good slap guys
that was a good slap well done guys well
done
oh my god we're in 90.
oh
we're almost there
you know originally originally i i was
like ah maybe i think i said this before
maybe i'll do like a thousand watches on
but man
i'm glad i did 100
i'm still not i wouldn't say i'm sick of
the trail yet i'm not it's still a good
trailer
but you know elden ring ain't gonna
this is your ship correct everyone type
slash everyone put like the hand emoji
or whatever when's the slap happens
that's like gonna be a real
unifier here they are in charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
91
boom
[Music]
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with sharepoint
embrace impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet captain
something is very weird
this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
you ever considered that there is no
right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who have trusted you which
means that if i'm seeing it i must be
crazy but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
[Music]
wow
i'll tell you that
i was asked this at the beginning i said
i would wait until the show comes out
but i'll just tell you right now that is
a real slap
that is a hundred percent a
oh real slap
and let me tell you we did that take
multiple times
yeah but it looks good though looks good
though
ah man all right we are at 90
[Applause]
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well we need
to have this situation all under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who have trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to begin
[Music]
wow
you guys better do your best to try to
watch this on a nice screen with a nice
sound system because my god this show is
going to sound amazing heist also sounds
amazing if you guys want to watch that
on a nice tv again if maybe the first
time you went through it just on your
phone or like your laptop speakers and
maybe you got a chance now to do it on a
nice screen
i say go for it it's
but this
beautiful 93
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible i mean it's our ship
actually this is the captain so
technically they are in charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well written
at this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
every mistake has cost the lives of
people who trusted you which means that
if i'm seeing it i must be crazy but i'm
not crazy
and everything
has to be
we gotta slap april 4th into the
collective brains of everybody who wants
to see this
wham
we're about to do 94
but just remember
april 4th
is my 10-year anniversary
by posting my first video
april 4
2012.
amnesia the dark descent part
one
i didn't even know how to edit i
literally recorded my microphone
to the fraps track
fraps and use fraps and ages and then i
dropped that in premiere and i just
rendered it out to repackage it because
you couldn't upload to youtube directly
this this is my 10-year anniversary
celebration
i think it's a pretty good one 94
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision
all under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go and they come back
and i always come back and everything
has to be
wow
i got good news guys i got good news
i have some amy approved behind the
scenes pictures to show you at the end
of this
we're going to be 95 which means we have
six left including the next one
it's weird it almost feels like a
countdown i haven't felt one of those in
a while
anyway 95
this is your [ __ ]
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy sing it along with me
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the cap technically they are in charge
you're in charge
[Music]
so
this ship is your responsibility
thank you
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shareholders
for impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is bearing
this situation all under control
it all comes down i wouldn't do that to
bad
[Applause]
you ever leadership that there is no
right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything
and everything
has to be
[Music]
wow
i really feel those slaps i really feel
them
i feel
five more
this is it
this is the big one well not this one
but five more and then it'll be the big
one
that'll be the big one
all right
actually let me preemptively move the
little
thing over so that there's room for when
that turns into a hondo
huh let's just keep going
96.
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
brace for impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well we need
to have this situation all under control
it all comes down i wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back
and they come back and i always come
back and everything
has to begin
oh
it's still good it's still good it's
still good april 4th who here
who who
who here tuned in at the beginning of
the stream and you're only tuning back
in now and realizing that i'm actually
going to do the thing told you i would
you shouldn't have doubted me at all
this is why you're tricked so easily
oh we're almost there in 96. notice a
man
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
under control
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
everything
has to be
wow
i had this realization
i had this realization that like i'm
watching this 100 times right and i'm in
97 just finished my 97th
and what's kind of crazy is i think back
to like when i first started youtube you
know and uh
you know you get
100 views on the first
like i wasn't even the first getting
that you know you get 100 views
and 100 views nowadays you know when you
know
just being perfectly honest my videos
get millions and
like this is how much time
is uh spent
cumulatively
just
watching even even 100 views and like
the amount of times that
i've been streaming for 4 hours and 38
minutes
like
i try to not lose perspective of things
but it's so easy to do over a period of
time but you know
that's time
people given time to watch something
that you make that's that's a
that's a precious thing so thank you
for your time
night
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with chef
impact
it's up to the captain
leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
come back can i go
back and i always come back and
everything
has to be
oh
it's still good i can't believe it i'm
still enjoying watching it
i just love it i just love it oh i can't
wait for you guys to see the full show i
cannot wait i cannot wait
ah
i want you to see it so bad
it's almost ready almost ready almost
ready few finishing touches
but
here comes 99
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shareholders
for impact
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet
captain something is very well wrapped
at this situation all under control
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
and everything
has to be
[Music]
still love it still love it still love
it okay
next up is the hundredth
watch
i've been streaming for four hours and
43 minutes so i made good time the
estimated first was about five six hours
i'm a little under that uh and i want to
say
this is no trixies i have the pictures
that i'm going to show with you or share
with you it's nothing groundbreaking
it's some uh just nice photography but
there's uh one picture that i know
you're gonna really want to see like i
know you want to see this one i'll leave
it for last but it's uh
it's really good i can't thank everyone
who worked on this enough
like
think of how much time i put into this
think of how many hours people put into
making this show just an idea that i had
and they
i think they're really proud of it i'm
really proud of it so
uh
get a friend to watch this with you and
if you have one nearby just grab them by
the scruff of the neck and drag them
over and then um
yeah also just
it's less than a month until the show
comes out
help me spread the word
help show that trailer that's literally
all you gotta do is just show them the
trailer if they're interested they're
interested if not not but it's a cool
trailer that's worth their time at least
i think so
did really show appreciation for all the
people who worked so hard on this one if
you did that for me so please
help me spread word about it you don't
have to do a live stream where you watch
it 100 times but uh
let a friend know that's all i ask
all right without further ado i'm
actually going to mute my microphone for
this one so there's no extra noise all
trailer
100
and remember the slap
all right
here we go
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge
oh you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with ship
brace for impact
it all comes down it wouldn't do that to
bad leadership
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before every mistake has cost the lives
of people who trusted you which means
that if i'm seeing it i must be crazy
but i'm not crazy
everything has today
can i go and i come back and i always
come back and everything
has to
[Music]
oh
oh she's a beaut
100
watches
[Laughter]
all right you earned this special
surprise i'm not gonna suddenly cut the
stream or anything um just some
behind-the-scenes pictures but i'm so
glad that you guys
for those of you who actually stuck it
over the hundred or if you just came
back thank you for being here
um
i'll just put these in order i guess so
these are uh oh actually let me go to a
different scene
i think uh if i go here
yeah this should be good
up here
okay
so what we have here let me actually
close this finally get out of there get
out of there
bring this over here bring this over
here okay
so these are the little sneaky peekies
don't get too excited there's no
spoilers i don't think anyway let me
double check but i trust amy here
um
yeah these are cool
yeah these are cool okay all right so we
gots uh like whoa that's too big
that's too big
hold on now hold on technical
difficulties hold on now hold on
let's try a little fit there we go
that's that's better okay so these are
going to come in
real big apparently
and i gotta
so this is just one of the little off
moments
please don't there oh my god
oh geez
careful
[Laughter]
hang on hang on hang on
hold the horse hold your horse hang on
oh my god uh
there
i know what i'm doing i know what i'm
doing i know what i'm doing okay so it's
just nice pick
um but like i said the last pick is the
one you want
no that's not right uh
that's another pick of me
there's pam uh
i'm not gonna say anything about these
pictures because like this is not about
commentaries just a little
little sneak peeks you know a little
little uh
little feast for the eyes but the last
one is the one that really matters
and then boop there's bob
i just love it i love it
love it
okay
and there's you know
you love them
mick
incredible
incredible just an incredible man
and then you get that okay that's enough
of that one uh
this
is post slap
or pre slap you know what i mean
that's what you get okay
we will discuss these in at length later
uh
there we go
ah that's a good one that's that's a
good one that's that's a fun one
again no explanation no
no nothing
no context you can figure it out for
yourself
uh
but this is the one that you want and i
know this is the one that you want so
look at it
in all its glory really drink it in you
could you can linger i'll let it linger
and uh
yeah i know this is what you want
oh there
she's so cute
like all the pretty stuff in the trailer
all the explosions all the vfx all the
characters nah the only thing that
matters is chica and you know what
well deserved
and you know there's tons of people
asking me questions you know about the
show and i'm not going to answer
anything about the show so just
take a look at that
and understand
that you are the captain of this ship
all of our lives are in your hands
and there's no one that i trust more
than you
to be our captain
i believe in you
chica believes in you
we know you won't let us down
so get ready
april 4th
that's when we set off
see on the ship captain